[Musica]
l'avevo già messo su facebook però
dovevo assolutamente di metterlo nel
blog perché ogni volta che lo guardo mi
ricordo più o meno quanto è il mio
quoziente intellettivo comunque per
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vj oggi siamo in un nuovo ma che
bel ami che un blog tranquillo lo facevo
da da un anno e mezzo prima di
cominciare questa stima stata vinta da
ugrave vaart che ha fatto questo disegno
della madonna tra l'altro la mia faccia
un misto tra preoccupazione e madonna
che piattone di pasta che mi hai fatto
non è le news the c'è per una volta
fosse l'unico vlog della vita dopo dico
delle news che sono insegnate di questo
momento praticamente ragazzi tutti tu
c'è anche mia nonna appunto wi fi piatti
di pasta ne avete chiesto faliva 36
mentre 56 questa cosa
adesso vi spiegherà di 20 ragazzi parla
registrazione del film che vi avevamo
già parlato sono stato 4 5 giorni in
hotel e poi mi sono trasferiti in questa
casa che praticamente registro i video
da qua questo per il prossimo mese ci
sarò e video da qui ed è una figata
pazzesca perché non ho mai vissuto fuori
da casa mia così tanto quindi non
esperienza della madonna ed è per questo
che vedete questo sfondo alquanto
sinistro
ecco questo era sinistra e per portare
tutta la roba quindi computer capelli
tutte le cuffie e tutta la roba che uso
per registrare per vivere anche quindi
anche il sesso perché io vivo nel cesso
mi ha aiutato trasportare roba un mio
amico perché da sola non ci avrei mai
fatto
diciamo che l'ho fatto leggermente
stancare
un ragazzo ecco quindi spiegato al
misero famiglia dove cazzo se ecco sono
vivo qui aveva fatto nello scorso blog
la domanda le ragazzi ma cosa posso fare
al posto dello scat aggio dei pacchi
visto che non sono più a casa non mi
arrivano i pacchi per questo blog
ragazzi ha deciso di fare un tour della
mia nuova casa assurda in tutte le sue
stranezze perché è veramente strano da
vi faccio una premessa io sono entrato
qui dentro che era già arredata ma come
è arredata non avete idea adesso vi
faccio vedere ai ragazzi per questa è la
mia postazione di gioco bellissima con
tanto di bottiglia e quello sono io che
sono un grafico lo stavo mettendo le
pagine this land airmen solo che non
essetre perché sono una persona pigra
messa in genere la romania tutto quello
che vedete c'era già tipo questa cosa
che la mattina prima di alzarmi piglio
ovviamente a schiaffi perché è una cosa
normale cioè della roba cose a caso il
pezzo forte della casa ragazzi il papa
dj che un soc
non chiedetemi cosa rappresenta prova
bene poi qua c'è uno si abbassino
purissimo che non so dove la luce
io questa cosa in ciò paura di notte non
lo apro mai qualcosa cosa che ho trovato
bellissime che c'è questa cesta con dei
marshmallow alla l'interna bellissima
ogni volta che entro in casa tipo cambi
bagni caldi valli questo è camera mia
vice letto lice ci sono dei televisori
qua ci sono dei porno che non sono miei
però di approvati qua ci sono tuttavia
mettere mie valigie che non ho mai messo
a posto
sto morendo soffocato c'è una ragnatela
grossa come la mia gamba è una cosa io
non vedo aragno che ha fatto quella
merda
scappo di casa che dice no faccia viva
niente faccio vedere casa mia era
tristezza
[Musica]
posso mettere quello che cazzo molto ed
è una figata come utile ragazzi da
quello che preferisco io è questo la
gente io non mi serva un cazzo però sono
un terrazzo che questo qui è
praticamente posso trovarmi fare sedie
oppure posso semplicemente decidere di
morire buttandomi giù comunque insomma o
vasta scelta teleschermi attaccate al
muro chi cazzo e vacui prima spider man
ci sono dei preservativi nel cassetto
ed è così che la ragazza quindi questa
era la mia casa era è ancora al cazzo
non vi dimenticate salire una cosa mi
che portanti ma soprattutto ciò ho
bruciato un fazzoletto e l'ho appeso al
muro
è passato un ufo abbiamo trovato la
nostra alternativa al palato scartato
dei pacchi le cose più storiche mi
succede non le vedete in diretta così
almeno siamo a posto
se doveste ragazzine che possiamo
passare al fa vi rispondo a prima non
andare vada a and futures mister rossoni
il computer allora io a partiti o
screenato questa domanda per il nome ma
che va bene che ti ringrazio molto
sei molto sexy soprattutto mi dice la
signora sconi il computer e lo devi
mettere sopra la testa perchè fa figo ma
per che cosa ci trovi di divertenti cala
e va poi risponde allora e mathis
svegliati capelli ma perché era che
mettete alle mie foto come foto profilo
io ho paura a guardare i commenti le
grandi premi sono tagliati i capelli
perché non ci stavo facendo più a vivere
ma vi ricresciuti 0,5 secondi quindi
alla fine di questo video ce l'avrò
praticamente come prima credo il
creatore di questo nome
mi scriva perché poi gli swan the fuori
cosa ti piace mangiare non si è capito
no o megal fa scriveva farisei pensi
vagamente di far ridere ma perché se
così illudersi fa male amico mio ma
pensi di avermi ferito nel profondo con
questo commento
no perché illudersi fa male quindi
ragazzi concluso vi confavi risponde
possono farvi domandare se mi dimentico
come al solito siete autorizzati a
venire sotto casa con le forche la fai
devo andare oggi ragazzi che cosa cazzo
c'è dentro il mio
inteso come essere vivente proprio
perché c'è qualcuno io so che c'è un
fantasma qualcosa io non entro
manco alla morte pro caccia ai ragazzi
se il video è piaciuto lasciato momento
mi piace anche a pagine di facebook e
come nei video tratta una descrizione se
voi siete iscritti non ci vediamo il
prossimo belle ragazze
[Musica]
because he
perché ragazzi sto per provare per la
prima [ __ ] volta a vedere che cazzo
c'è nello sgabuzzino quello che mi fa
una paura tremenda forse posso morire in
diretta ma quello è un dettaglio ci
siamo ragazzi